Wonka is not without its controversies
starting with hug Grant as an Umpa
lumper one of The Lovable tiny humanoids
whom Wily Wonka claimed he took in as
refugees but has been accused of
exploiting for cheap labor and maab
Rhymes George cman is a British actor
with dwarfism who told the BBC a lot of
actors with dwarfism feel like we are
being pushed out of the industry we love
a lot of people myself included argue
that dwarfs should be offered everyday
roles in dramas and soaps but we aren't
getting offered those roles one door is
being closed but they have for Forten to
open the next one copin is referring to
new sensitivities in Hollywood whereby
filmmakers may be reluctant to cast
actors with dwarfism in roles like umper
lumpers or Snow White Seven Dwarfs
however they remain equally reluctant to
cast them in standard acting roles that
have nothing to do with their physical
size it's a thorny issue and not one
that's likely to be resolved anytime
soon